once everybody in this room and this
space understands what i just talked
about it doesn't matter what the
language is going to say you're never
going to sign a deal in the first place
when you just know like yo
let's just
sell it to our fans when you have 7
million followers on tick tock you're
going to find 10 000 people that can
give you 800 bucks for a piece of your
back end
800 bucks times 10 000 adds up
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
and this is the incomparable gary vee
he's going to come up with your hands
together
[Applause]
it's good to be here hope everyone's
good um
just want to chop a little bit on nfts
and music
since i feel like it's appropriate might
as well take advantage of the moment
i think um
i think a lot of
a lot of what's gone through a lot of
people's minds in here about the music
industry is about to really happen it
took a lot of pieces of the puzzle
to get to this point and the point is
the following of
pretty much starting as of this moment
we're in the beginning of the process
of the economics of the music industry
shifting pretty aggressively
and the people that are going to be the
big winners
are
the human beings that come up with the
music
and the human beings that support that
music
and the people that are gonna be the
losers of this next century were the
biggest winners of the last century
which was
everybody in between that
so
what i mean by that is
now that we have the blockchain
the consumer blockchain
nfts something strange is happening that
most people don't understand
the reason everyone's so [ __ ] up and
like either way too excited or
completely
confused by nfts is because everybody's
bringing their internet brain to the
party
everyone's looking at nfts
through the lens of what they know about
the internet for the last 25 years
the problem is
it's not the internet
the internet is all the [ __ ] we know and
made all our lives better and more
interesting and all the [ __ ] we [ __ ]
with
but the blockchain is a completely
different infrastructure
it's servers
that are decentralized that nobody owns
and what that means
is it creates
what it is which is a ledger
that can document things which means
you can actually own digital assets
for real not like
right click and save and all the jokes
people make about nfts when people make
jokes about i'm just going to right
click and save this it's funny because
the reality is you can fake [ __ ] in real
life and on social media much more than
you can fake [ __ ] on the blockchain
everybody here can borrow somebody's
watch or jewelry take a photo and try to
flex like they own it on the blockchain
the person that owns it owns it and
anybody in the world can see it
what does that mean for everybody in
here it means
the following
between spotify and soundcloud
and
especially tick-tock people can now be
discovered people can blow up
the a r business for record labels has
changed forever you used to go out and
have to go out to stuff like this go to
places you have to actually physically
go and find people
now people just lay in bed and just see
who's trending on tiktok
people get famous now before they get
signed as everybody in here knows at
scale
at scale
it's not an occasional thing now it's
the normal thing
what does that mean it means that people
start amassing fans at scale before they
sign a deal it means that they can put
that music on distribution and get their
pennies on the dollar in the way it
works
the only reason
which is unfair the main reason
that people sign deals
is because the upfront bag changes their
life
the reason people sign deals is because
that million dollars or that two million
dollars really [ __ ] means something
when you've never seen money like that
and people get locked into deals where
they make a record deal you know this
and you gotta a pay back that 2 million
b all the money they spent on promoting
you you got to pay that back and after
all that 2.8 or if you got 500 000 and
30 000 after that 530 comes in from your
music then you start getting 20 cents
and they get 80 cents maybe if you got
crazy leverage you could be 50 50 on
that
what's gonna happen next is the most
important part that everybody here has
to listen to
what the future of music is gonna be
is you're going to explode on tick tock
or whatever the [ __ ] is tick tock of the
day
and what's going to happen is you're
going to drop your first album and
you're going to sell
a thousand 5 000 or 10 000 nfts
that represent your upfront bag
so instead of taking a million
or 500 000 or 2 million or 10 million
from a record label
you're going to take that same amount of
money from your fans
but your fans are only going to get 20
maybe if that's how you want to roll 50
of the back end
but you're gonna control it
and you're gonna get that upfront money
from your fans
and when you pop off
your fans are gonna make money
just imagine that just really think
about that
exactly
it's important it's really important
because here's what's gonna happen it's
gonna change the entire relationship
with music and fans forever
mike boyd
who here knows mike boyd give him a
little love
[Applause]
if the if this blockchain existed 20
years ago i'd be working for mike boyd
mike boyd would have bought nfts of mac
miller and wiz khalifa
and nicki minaj and nipsey and everybody
else he showed me when they had [ __ ]
5 000 fans 3 000 fans 200 fans on
twitter
you can watch the videos of ghana in our
office in 2018.
it was all right there and mike boy
would have taken his pennies that he had
scraped them together and bought nfts
that got a little piece of this and a
little piece of that and would have kept
winning and would have made a huge bet
on somebody own five or ten percent of
their back end and would be collecting
royalties every single day
the fact that artists
are going to make their fans rich when
they hit is [ __ ] crazy
it also changes the psychology of the
entire relationship different now you've
got fans who are financially
incentivized for you to win
the fans become the promoters because
they get a back end this is a big
[ __ ] deal forever
every record label in the world now
lost its final piece it used to be
distribution you had to sign a deal
because you weren't going to be on
[ __ ] bet mtv or any radio z100 you
weren't even going to be heard then the
[ __ ] internet came along
it took care of that part
then you had to be then you signed deals
because they put you on [ __ ] trl with
[ __ ] carson and all those kids saw
you and you'd be like oh he's she's cool
well tick tock took care of that you're
one song away from having more people
watch your videos than all of trl's big
ass audience in 1999.
the last piece was the hardest the
economics
how the money moves
how you as an artist could actually get
a big enough dollar amount that made you
not sign
there's a reason and by the way
on the record record labels aren't bad
they're really not they're in business
for everybody that they [ __ ] make
money on they put out a million dollars
to 97 people that [ __ ] sucked
so they're just doing their thing i have
no by the way just like on wax no issues
with record labels
i just think people have better options
now people are going to make more money
dropping an nft of their mixtape sharing
their royalties with their fans which is
going to feel better imagine who the f
who the [ __ ] do you think you want
making money on you
the [ __ ] first ten thousand people
that [ __ ] with you when nobody gave a
[ __ ] about you
so
i really really really hope everybody in
this room is really paying attention
because in 94 and five and six when i
was spitting internet [ __ ] everybody
shook their head and nobody did [ __ ]
about it
when i was [ __ ] talking twitter and
youtube and [ __ ] facebook in 2005 and
six in places like this everyone shook
their head yeah yeah nobody did [ __ ]
about it
this is a real [ __ ] forever changing
moment of music
forever
all publishing movies you want to make a
movie fund it through an nft you want to
write a book
fund it through an nft
but the first thing you have to do is
build an audience
content is always going to be king
you got to build real relationships i've
dm with a bunch of you in the past i
watch a lot of you move i watch
everybody move that's what i do for a
living there's a lot of people who want
a million followers but they don't take
care of the first thousand followers
which is why they'll never get there
you want to really get to this nirvana
place i just told you about start loving
every [ __ ] person that [ __ ] with you
reply to their dms reply back in their
comments
show love that's how you get it back
thank you
[Applause]
anybody got questions
you disrupted the advertising industry
how
do you think with nfts
like disrupt advertising in that space
it's been huge for us we launched vayner
nft
budweiser pepsi have two two of the most
successful nft projects it's made
everybody and we did that
and it's made every brand rethink
marketing
because
marketing
is
a crazy game
every day i'm in the game with people
that are supposed to be the cmos of the
biggest brands in the world
and there's nothing marketing going on
in there it's all boardroom [ __ ]
politics everybody doing old [ __ ] who
the [ __ ] watches a television commercial
besides the one that airs this sunday
nobody
who even watches regular television it's
all streaming it's all social so
it's going to disrupt it in a weird way
because they're all going to get into
nfts and they're gonna feel what actual
consumer work does and by the way
there's been a bunch of brands that have
launched nfts that nobody even here
knows about because nobody bought one
and so they're learning like wait a
minute if that didn't work is our
commercials and so it's like the nft
success and non-success is putting
pressure on the way they're thinking
about marketing
so i think that's going to be the
biggest impact because it's going to be
about merit because you can't hide in
nft land
you know all these numbers where people
debate whose albums sold more and this
and that nielsen's all that that's all
fake data
you can't hide
in nft landing your nft sold or they
didn't it's all public domain on the
blockchain nobody owns the information
it's all right there
this
fakers are about to get to smoke the
[ __ ] out
thank god
because a lot of you [ __ ] fake [ __ ]
what industry do you feel nfts won't
disrupt
because i feel like those are the ones
we need to start attacking now
but also
what do you feel you did differently
with b friends than other people did
with their nfts because [ __ ] a lot of
[ __ ] just sitting
thank you i think i think b2b will take
a while
it's gonna be a while before we really
figure out there's a lot of supply chain
there's a lot of interesting [ __ ] that
blockchain can do but i think b2b will
be slower
it'll take some time before so that's
something to think about
man i think look it this isn't this is
why i keep comparing it to the internet
this is an all-encompassing technology
there's
every receipt
every receipt of everything you buy
should be an nft it's in the company's
vested interest and it's your best
interest now you're just crumpling a
piece of paper when you walk out but if
that shit's got a chance of being worth
something because they used an emerging
artist to make your receipt you're going
to hold you're going to hold on to it
and you and by the way you don't do
anything about it goes right into your
wallet right so like it's gonna be a
very big deal as far as v friends
i think what i did differently was the
things i did the 15 years leading up to
the launch
the same thing you did when they told
you you're gonna [ __ ] your father's
company
yeah i mean that part was different you
know what he's referring to is when i
told everybody that i was gonna take my
dad's store online in 95 67 everybody
laughed and a lot of people because my
dad came to america with nothing he
built up and he had a lot of friends in
the business and they were like scared
that i was really gonna ruin my dad's
life
that's different that's just
chip on shoulder [ __ ] that i love so
much
um
no i think
what i did different was the biggest
problem with nft projects right now is
everyone's like
i got to build a community on discord so
i can sell 10 000 nfts in a week
and like i get dm's like yo gary v i got
to build a discord community because my
launch is in two weeks what do i do i'm
like shut it down
here
yeah it's it's just it's it's it's
audacity
the biggest issue
actually one of the biggest things that
i think about with music a lot because
i've met a lot of artists
when you're an artist or an entrepreneur
one of the biggest challenges is to
balance selfish and selfless
the biggest issue right now in nft land
is
nobody that hits me up and a million
people hit me up on this [ __ ]
when i tell you one percent are actually
giving a [ __ ] about the other side
everyone's just worried about how much
money they're gonna make how fast how
easy
everyone's in gold rush which is why by
the way the other reason i say that 98
is going to zero is because it is
because everyone's out here on some
[ __ ] beanie baby [ __ ]
right quick flip let me get mine
not giving a [ __ ] about somebody
spending
i had this one kid i was like bro you're
about to try to sell
a picture
of a [ __ ] turtle with a burrito
that's his ass for eight thousand
dollars a piece and you don't give a
[ __ ] what's going to happen to the
person that spends 8 000 on it in a week
that's where we're at right now and it's
unfortunate and what's going to happen
like to me i'm pretty excited about it
because what's going to happen is
shit's going to hit the fan
everyone's going to like see it was a
scam it was a fad
everyone's going to walk away and go on
to the next thing
and that's what i'm gonna swoop up and
really [ __ ] do some damage
i might buy the knicks and the jets
that's that's how that's how big i think
the opportunity will be when everybody
walks away in a year or two whenever
this [ __ ] hits the fan everyone's gonna
bounce because people's feelings and
money's going to be hurt
if you put 35k into 17 different nfts
thinking you're about to buy a [ __ ]
mansion in the hills and all that [ __ ]
goes to zero
you're not gonna have appetite to come
back in so quick
especially when you only have 41 000 to
start with or worse 16 and you're in
debt
people out here being crazy
and then they're going to blame
nfts without blaming themselves the [ __ ]
are you buying 40 000 worth of nfts when
you got 11 000 to your name
that's people
so you want to be like the pocket player
that seems like it's the most safety
that's my whole life that's what i've
been
like i never overextend myself my [ __ ]
is so calculated my energy throws people
off and they think i'm crazy or wild
they're up to some [ __ ] but i'm [ __ ]
that's strategic yeah you know like that
whole saying of like measured twice cut
once i measure a thousand times before i
cut because my problem is when i cut i
get loud
i only know one way if i'm gonna eat i
want everybody that gives me a minute of
their time to eat along with me if they
understand what i'm saying
so
when i decided that this was the thing i
just started making content the next day
and i'm not worried about convincing
anybody
all my friends are like how are we going
to convince everybody like we're not
don't convince have conviction
i'm not trying to convince anybody about
this [ __ ] you don't believe me mazel tov
go do you i'll see you in three years
we'll talk
so that's where i'm at i'm not trying to
convince anybody about nothing
i have a question
make the please
i know
it's just when they resell
the the nft no
two ways for the artist this is why it's
crazy for the artist think about this
you sell 10 000 of your pieces
of your initial album drop the art is
the [ __ ] album art right different
versions you sell it
mike's like yo this person's gonna be
big i buy a hundred of them the person
starts being big and the nfts start
making money i might sell off some of
the original pieces
the original artist is gonna get a five
or ten percent commission just on that
so i might buy it for 400 bucks sell it
for 5 000 and you the artists are going
to get another 500 bucks on 10 percent
on that 5 000 but the money that's one
part that's that's transactional
royalties what's gonna happen over time
and we're not there yet but there's a
lot of companies working on it is
this album
just like with producers or record label
they'll be a split
and the split's gonna be with the fan
got it so
when if the weekend dropped his first
album on a blockchain nft because the
world was further along or further
behind however you want to look at it
and if you bought one nft it might
represent 0.3 0.01 percent whatever the
math is of the royalties and every
[ __ ] month when spotify is sending
out money
70 goes to the weekend and 30 goes to 10
000 people
that's what royal and a bunch of other
companies are working on right now we're
12 18 24 months away from this being
real as [ __ ] and people sitting around
being like [ __ ]
and that's why record labels are going
to have to evolve into a different
animal
because
they are already harder
to take their attic language
like they're trying to of course they
are once everyone gets you know just
like a lot of things where people wait
longer i mean
again there's a lot of ogs in here 20
years ago people signed deals fast
now they signed deals a little slower
right people a little bit more
thoughtful trying to build more leverage
once everybody in this room and this
space understands what i just talked
about it doesn't matter what the
language is going to say you're never
going to sign a deal in the first place
when you just know like yo
let's just
sell it to our fans when you have 7
million followers on tick tock you're
going to find 10 000 people that can
give you 800 bucks for a piece of your
back end
800 bucks times 10 000 adds up
so if you're saying those contracts
won't matter and essentially all it's
going to matter is our smart contracts
what if what happens when the blowout
happens what happens to smart contracts
things
cancel the validity no the blow up right
now is because everything's about
collectibility what we're talking about
here is utility the real reason the
blockchain is going to matter
right so
no i mean to your point if the timing
works where nfts crash just as the
technology is there there may be like a
six or 12 month window where it drags
out longer than it would have had if it
was hot as [ __ ] like right now
but this is [ __ ] inevitable
this is this is a wrap
there's like there's no logical reason
for this not to be the biggest this is
what every artist will aspire to people
instead of aiming for a deal
will settle for a deal if they weren't
able to sell
or big enough
fan bases
of course you mentioned uh 10 000 a
couple times did you see that as maybe
no that's just that's just you know
that's why crypto punks was such a big
deal they established the 10th that's
just that's the lingo now it could be
you can do three
you want to sell
three nfts that represent you want to
sell
four nfts that represent 25 each of 30
percent that you want to sell to your
fans and you want 25 you want 500k you
know this this is all gonna be market
dynamics 10 000 is just the number that
most nft projects of last year were
built around but you're seeing a lot of
evolution in that
b
yeah my question was more so like uh
like your thoughts on music you got all
these musicians in here you got all
these artists all these creators
and
you know we doubled down on
collaboration and in order to change
the ecosystem or the powers that be it
has to be at the form of collaboration
can you
expand more on like the nfts
and the blockchain and the bear splits
to artists musicians i'm so excited
about that just like
what we just talked about which is like
label an artist
the fact that all the [ __ ] that all
these artists go through the producer
the writer the [ __ ] like it's so
complicated it gets so political the
fact that it's just so easy to sit like
it will be as easy in 10 years everybody
like every 14 year old right now by the
time they're 24
like sitting down in studio and just
cutting the deal be like 7 nine ten boom
like it's going to be remarkable and
never have to think about it again no
[ __ ] auditing and did i really get
[ __ ] and the label was really [ __ ]
with them and they [ __ ] me
nah it's just gonna be right there so i
think
what's what's amazing about that is when
there is that level of true transparency
it actually allows for collaboration to
be easier because a lot of humans by
nature are cynical
fear-based they don't feel like they're
educated
so for a lot of people here when they
came up like
there's almost nobody who's not scared
to make a bad deal
right it's just fear so i think i'm
really excited about that transparency
and that simplicity because then you get
into such basic math
you just have to be able to count to a
hundred and you'll be able to figure it
out hey you're talking about you know
like closing the gap right so there's a
huge gap and
a lot of you know people of color uh
women you know there's a huge gap and in
order you know what i mean
it's the best part of the blockchain
exactly the blockchain is finally
decentralized
blockchain doesn't know who the [ __ ] you
are
where you came from what you do who you
are like it's a big big big deal
it's a humongous deal it's a big deal
but
with the with all that the blockchain's
about to do something else
it's about to eliminate excuses
because the number one thing people are
about to wake up to
is when you can't point fingers on the
algorithm
you'll spotify [ __ ] me
on the label
they're racist when you when you
eliminate every [ __ ] excuse
people about to find out how good they
really are
you know this as an athlete my favorite
thing about athletes is they love to
blame the coach
it is because fall
as an artist that do album covers
is it wise enough to say in your
contract i want to know i want to own
the nft of this album it's going to be
better than that
when you catch the right kid on the come
up and if you're fire if you're a fire
designer and you get one percent of the
[ __ ] deal do you know what one
percent of thriller is
the but that's beautiful because like
there may be a lot of people that buy an
nft of a emerging artist
that they never heard of but they bought
it because of the fire art
like you're gonna get yours now
and it'll be different things at first
like there's just there's so many
variables to this like you may get two
percent
right but then the market may be flooded
with a ton of fire artists and then all
of a sudden you can't get two percent
but to your point you might take
ten you know ten nfts and if that thing
is the friends and they're forty
thousand so there's just like so much
new dynamics that are going to be
negotiated out but i'm excited because i
think there's some artists that are
going to with one album drop
forever change their life
from like more of like a literal
standpoint right let's just say
hypothetically me and you do a song
yep right sounds like a plan
i make the track yep you give me some
lyrics yes
i need
i need some [ __ ] auto tune go ahead i
give you a little gun
or even if you just get the lyrics and
not perform because i don't know about
your vocals yet right that's right i
i know about my vocals
go ahead so so i say all right well
let's let's put this 50 50
and
and drop this as an nft
uh
in in
today's vibe right now
are
straight to consumer platform and
something like a distro kid that's right
we'll just go and we can just split it
50 50. that's exactly right as it
streams that's right go straight to you
that's right in nft space what's the
there is the nfc that exists yeah the
nft will be minted and connected to
distro
and and so the royalty of the music will
go through that way they'll be connected
and the royalty of the nft because
because i might think it's like again
back to mike boyd's career how it's
going to change is now we're going to be
looking for [ __ ] and he's like yo
i mean we just went through with this i
mean this is like i'm looking right in
front of you i'm looking at the dude
that this just happened with me and him
we're like we found him we're like this
kid right and so in that scenario if you
two had been working together instead of
just dming him being like yo we [ __ ]
with you maybe we can do something in
the future
i'm going to go and buy 15 nfts to have
a piece of his work
and in that scenario somebody sold that
to me so there's royalties on the nfts
if if you guys were just minding it from
the beginning you guys would get that
money but if but if my brother aj bought
them and he relisted it for double and i
bought them then he's going to get the
profit but you're going to get 10
percent of the nft profit and then you
guys would split that maybe it's 49 49
and 2 for the designer that will happen
on in a different place that will happen
in your wallets
in crypto land the music will still
happen through distrokit and it happens
automatically right automatically
that's why it's so big
to change the game
where is the base on prices for music
like with the single or a video
that we should have been thinking about
i know we can put it any price we want
likely
it completely matters on the demand from
your consumer there's gonna be people
are gonna drop an album
for [ __ ] trying to raise ten thousand
dollars ten thousand at a dollar a piece
that are gonna sell four
four dollars
because nobody [ __ ] with them
so that that's completely completely no
different than the historic nature of
albums
being done through
record labels record labels have put out
and given out all sorts of different
checks dependent on how much heat you
had
this is why it keeps going back to the
thing i said very subtly i'll say it
again
the quicker people actually build an
audience that actually [ __ ] with them
the better
and the problem is people are just not
doing the right behavior
like artists out here thinking they're
bringing value to their fans by taking a
photo of them wearing some new fresh
[ __ ] kit hoodie
what the [ __ ] are you bringing value to
what the [ __ ] does that bring value to
your audience
the big money decides all right we see
what y'all doing
when you release something we don't come
in and buy all this [ __ ] up cause we got
you you don't give a [ __ ]
you don't give why would you give a [ __ ]
i make the price higher it's [ __ ] but
then that takes away from your fans
fans need to move quicker
um
big you know what's amazing is you
listen you want to create a friends list
a white list a list beforehand for just
your fans like there's a you'll learn
all the nft games the things that me
phil we're all going through like even
in a year the [ __ ] got crazy because
there's a lot of money involved
the whales come in and they just want to
write a [ __ ] code script and buy 5
000 of them
but
yep
but let me say this
the greatest hope i hope for everybody
in this room is that you have enough
heat on your first album that you ever
put out that people want to buy it like
that i think more more realistically the
majority of un like emerging
artists are gonna have to hustle and
grind to sell out their first thing it's
not gonna sell out in a minute
right
but that's what's amazing about tick
tock see you've got like seven things
going on at once
right like
it might just i mean you got two guys
here who went through real [ __ ] viral
moments
one song one moment one deal one video
got you next uh for visual entries i
know that a lot of people are talking
about future proofing them for the
metaverse that they're available um as
mostly musicians in the room do they
need to be worried about the metaverse
in that manner or how do they
my take on the metaverse is a little bit
further away than people realize like
everyone's hot on it but like nobody's
really living in vr yet
i mean look at ar it's like almost it's
like
when did pokemon go come out
you know
more yeah like you know
if you i talk about something thank god
i didn't make a video about
i would have been so crazy wrong if you
told me that we're here six or whatever
years later and there hasn't been a
single viral
ar app execution since i thought every i
thought marvel
and poe like [ __ ] hello kitty and
wrestling like i'm blown away
new technologies like real new
technologies take a while
let me remind everybody nfts hit hard in
2017. nobody here was buying crypto
kitties in 2017.
like it takes time for new new
technology so it's something people
should be aware of everybody here should
be doing homework
right we're in class right now it's
homework
you know it's real homework but i
wouldn't get crazy yet because we're a
little further away i think people are
going to lose a lot of money on buying
land
i really do
i really do because it's too early we
don't even know which one's going to win
and it's going to be a hardware game
oculus is gonna like meta's like got a
big chance to win that
my man you've been patient thank you
um to follow up on cosine's question yep
um the practical process of creating a
song minting it into an nft and
distributing it
through something that already exists
like distro kid are you saying that the
nft that is the music or the album will
be somewhat of like a
take place up like an mp3 or a window
i'm saying it represent it could and
people will create but the concept is it
is a contract
that's why you keep hearing the term
smart contract the nft is the contract
it says
gary you get point three percent of all
the royalties and if i buy 30 of those
now i got one point right got it
so that
and by the way the platform that i'm
referring to doesn't fully exist yet
there's people working on it phil is
we're looking at every startup in it
because he knows that like like it'll be
self-explanatory when it comes
you'll just go right in like wordpress
and like mint
and the examples of people who've done
it already like you mentioned uh your
colleagues that are here who have um had
success with nft music like what was
what was their process
i'm not referring to that i'm talking
about i'm referring to like actual music
hits not nft music my man so i'm in the
web brief space i'm already selling
music nfcs but right now it's very much
so like the wild west yes um there's no
centralized platform
no truly centralized platform for music
nfcs when there's mass adoption and
everybody in this room is releasing
music and mcs do you see traditional
dsps catching up to that place or do you
think they're just going to be brand new
uh i guess nft platform i think the dsps
that are in place are gonna don't forget
they're consumer facing they're gonna
still win
but to your point
it'd be hard not to think somebody's
going to pop out a matter
you know
there's just too many people that are
vying for that spot
spotify's got all its own you know it's
going to go through its thing right now
like there's going to be a lot of
movement plus the ship pops up all the
time but i think we're thinking more and
more about owning versus
services
it's just such a big moment you know
gee what do you think is um so fun
artists right let's say a new artist
coming into the game
what is that new team look like because
yeah
yeah i need a producer
i need a videographer
what does that look like now i think i
think the designer becomes a much bigger
player in the game because it's gonna be
visual collector so i think the designer
becomes a new one and now i think
the actual
promoter
because because the man whether it's
managers whether it's record labels
like
you're gonna need the person that can
actually get people to buy [ __ ] right
salesperson mm-hmm
i think those person designed it
for first a
new artist they don't have all the
budget so it's like the good thing is
for a new artist this is gonna be huge
listen to this part big
for a new artist
that doesn't have budget
now saying to their boy
who they've seen
like their friend who was the best at
selling [ __ ] candy in school and
you're like that kid can sell [ __ ] you
can go to that kid now and be like yo i
can't pay you but you can have three
percent of this project
right that's a big deal yeah that's not
something they could promise before
right
i mean i i just think about myself and
who i became i would have that's the
only [ __ ] i would have done in high
school
i would have just that would have been
my life i wouldn't have sold baseball
cards i would have promoted music and
try to hit one
because the royalties are in perpetuity
like think about that imagine catching
nirvana in 1991 in high school and
getting three percent of every teen
spirit play forever
i don't think people understand right
like like i remember like when the
weekend buys his big home you're like
you forget royalties is the real
business that's why music people make
money it's why seinfeld is so rich he
got into the deal on stun right on uh
what do they call it in tv um
syndication you know like this is real
economics
record i want to remind you and you guys
all know this
record labels almost always miss
almost everybody they sign fails
so think about how big those companies
are so think about how much money you
make when somebody does it
yeah
so the label gives you a budget say it's
750 you know to release you know
um
chances are you ain't really need them
to record the album but you need them
for marketing video budgets etcetera
apologize that this is not no it's never
done it can you walk me through
how
an artist can go about
raising that capital
fans
artist says you're going to get my
you're going to get royalties to my
project
i'm going to you haven't heard yet
it depends how you want to play it right
like maybe you heard a single that you
heard well listen if you're going to be
somebody that has fans to talk to you
did something
right like something happened
right
unless you're very attractive
seriously unless you're going that route
like and you're making a transition to
music you're
probably got fans because you put out
some music on tik tok or what have your
sound cloud right so they already got a
feel right but what's crazy is like fans
[ __ ] with all of you because music's
[ __ ] universal it's one of the most
important things in our society's
history
but now you're gonna have entrepreneurs
like i'm gonna pay attention to mike's
texts way more now
because there's money involved
and the reason
but i'm being serious right as a lot of
you know especially ones that have
noticed for a while our music journey is
about pure and utter karma and love
we've been out here for a decade
people probably been waiting for our
other shoe to drop we just give give
give that's just how we've lived but now
when mike's like yo check this out
we have such a good combo because he's
listening to a lot of stuff
and like we have this crazy track record
because when we both fully agree
like if we're both at an 11
a lot of those people have gone on to do
work and just something in our combo of
like what we both kind of hear when we
come from different places sometimes we
don't like the same stuff but when we
both like it there's been a really good
track record well now
i'm gonna i'm gonna look at that and be
like yo i'm gonna buy that project i'm
gonna mint 50 units and so that 750
comes from your fans
you run the budget so you sell them nfts
and they get
of an image
right
again remember you could do anything you
could do a hundred hundred album covers
design a hundred different ways so
there's some collectibility give away
twenty percent and thirty percent
down into whatever you got it and then
that gets you 750.
that's it
and so what's crazy my man
the the fans become the label
the fans become the label
it's super lit
because it's gonna feel double good for
the [ __ ] artist a
your economics are gonna be better
don't forget
from you know
when when you make the fans
the label you're to be sharing with them
from penny number one so now you come
out you have a hit
and money's coming in you're getting 70
cents they're getting 30 cents with the
album deal the first 750 goes to them
then you get your 20 cents on the dollar
you're getting 70 cents a dollar from
day one
this is a very big deal
how far away do you think we are from
that first dorky fan becoming like a
multi-millionaire
within five
and when that dorky fan becomes a
million wait till you see that tick tock
viral video
wait till you see that kid saying i made
100k this week because i believed in
blank blank blank and they went up it's
super beautiful think about think about
all those kids that want to be
influencers or artists when they hear
that they're gonna be like [ __ ] that i'm
gonna be a music investor
like imagine telling your mom to shut up
because you're listening to music and
you're working
it's a really i'm tell listen i really
want everybody to hear this there's a
couple there's a lot of youngsters here
but there's just enough people in here
of the age that are going to know what
i'm about to say
nobody understood how big the internet
was in 95.
people thought it was the information
superhighway
it was it was like a better encyclopedia
right it's all it was a better
encyclopedia i remember telling my
friends in school in 97 98 that
everybody was gonna online date and they
laughed like nah that's for 500 pound
fat dudes in their mom's basement and
now everyone's just swiping left and
[ __ ] right sliding into dms the [ __ ]
[ __ ] changes the world changes
i'm telling you everybody's
underestimating the blockchain everybody
it's that big because everybody keeps
thinking it's the internet it's not the
internet the end it's as if the internet
didn't exist and here came a new [ __ ]
but the difference is the blockchain's
in place with the mature internet
right right right because if the
blockchain came out
my mood dude right if that came out
first
and cool but how the [ __ ] are you gonna
get anybody know who you are there's no
internet there's no tick tock there's no
spotify so you gotta sign with the label
because they're gonna print your [ __ ]
cds and they're gonna put you on trl
so it needed everything they needed
everything distribution
marketing
and
a ledger that could run the economics
now you got all the pieces now
now
it's going to get interesting
yeah does the does the artist make money
off of the fans reselling nmt yes
left
just came in
i think i want to break it down again so
now you're doing the royalty thing
now
mike for example mike sold a b friend
huge mistake
but he needed the money he taught mike
hit me up he's like i'm going to sell
this
he's like i just need i need that i need
the paper right now i'm like it hurts
but i respect it and you got to do
what's good for you so he sold it made
plenty of money
right when mike sold it
i made 10 percent
but but this is important with music
think about how it's going to work out
this is why the artist is going to win
twice
so now you put out the nfts for the
percentages of the back end you pop off
now people are there's i'm more about eq
branding i'm more energy but there's
some people that are math
and people are just gonna run math and
be like okay this this they're just
gonna look at hardcore math and be like
this artist hasn't even hit the apex yet
they've got historical data running big
quant and they're like i think this
artist could be number one for another
13 weeks they're going to run back the
math figure out what spotify is kicking
you and they're going to go in and buy
other people that if they're going to be
like [ __ ] it i'll buy his nft for 50
more than it is right now
because i know i'll make it back in 15
weeks
right and so you'll sell you bought an
nft for [ __ ] 400 bucks to get a piece
now you're selling it for 4 000 you made
some money on royalties and you sold the
nft for 4 000 but the artist gets 400 on
that transaction or 200 depends on what
the math is on the royalty so there's
double royalty economics for the artist
the contract they make money on every
time it transacts and obviously the
royalties of the music so now artists
could be playing in two places
sorry don't worry someone um
buys the nft so someone sells it and
then someone buys it do it now own part
of the song yeah
it's going to transfer over
henry
who bought it
yeah the original owner's out
just like michael jackson bought the
masters to the beatles and then sold it
right this is going to be the much much
smaller version but it's exactly the
same thing
so we this keeps being a project based
thing can an nft
own a llc can i can i make my llc or
business an nft
not the answer is going to be yes
but right now
there's not enough clarity from the sec
there's there's like there we need a
little bit more and even the music
things got to go through its thing but i
think the music thing is further long
accepted then i'm thinking more like the
royalties and like i was splitting are
you saying like if you're an early bet
on a project
you're early better my business my man
my number one thing on earth that i'm
waiting for is for the government to to
give us clarity on this because
if god forbid they make it easy and they
say yes then v friends series one is
gonna be the greatest nft of all time
because my mental big plan is every
business that i ever opened for the rest
of my life i'm gonna give a piece to the
people that own beef friends series one
that's that's what i'm doing that's
exactly what you're thinking the right
way there's still some security laws
things that have to come through so you
want them to regulate
yeah
i do want them to regulate
yeah i just want to know what the rules
are
i'll beat everybody as long as
everyone's playing the same rules
you know
and by the way all the [ __ ] you hear is
not real like the tax law is clear i'm
playing plenty of taxes this year
like
like there's the tax laws are very clear
there's things like that that are not
clear whether it's a security or not a
collectible and that like so there's
some things to think through
so they'll try to put capital gains on
it well there is capital gain so we
friends when i sell the v friend i have
to pay ordinary income on it
like flat out
but i get ethereum
if i hold that ethereum for longer than
a year
then i pay cap gains because they treat
it as that got it
[Music]
but then there's all sorts of [ __ ] like
you might want to wash it and capture
some losses i mean there's just so many
things that people have to think through
what should we study first in the
30-hour
journey
what was your blueprint for when you
doubled [ __ ] what is an nft enter
and read and read and read like it was
such basic everyone here is a little
further along but most of you aren't and
that's okay you know what it is but you
don't really like some of you are
listening right now but you gotta maybe
for you like for me
youtube was strong because you give me
visual and audio i can't read for no
reading comprehension
so like i didn't read anything it was
all videos audio i'm very good at micro
reading so i did a ton of discord and
twitter and just read [ __ ] when i fell
in love with crypto punks
after like five hours of that then i
spent five hours literally googling and
searching on twitter like
crypto punks scam crypto punk's bad
crypto punks not worth it like i was
trying to find like the biggest mistake
that people make is they get high on
something and then they'll spend a
minute on the counterpoint
i do a lot of that because i'm scared to
be wrong because that's my whole my
whole thing is this but when i'm doing
my heart right now being right
right and so like i have to do a lot of
work before i'm willing to go out here
and be i mean if this all ends up being
wrong i'm finished with all of you this
has been a pretty
passionate rant on this thing
you know
but my track it's what i love about my
track record when when like i'm on some
new [ __ ] whether it's tick-tock or this
and of course you get so much you know
counter-hate and i was like yeah a clock
hits right twice i always go in i'm like
yo show me the video where i said
something
wrong because i'll show you all the ones
that are right show me the wrong ones
that which is why i do so much homework
before i'm gonna
my reputation is my currency
do you think it's important to mint on
your own site before opening up on like
a open season you don't you don't have
to but i do think that's getting easier
and less expensive every day and better
tools are being built and i think that's
just the way people are going to do it
but
meta old facebook has been got a lot of
smoke coin base a lot of smoke
my prediction is right now open c
is the player and that looks like ebay
i think
this year is going to be the year that
we see things like i don't know how much
you guys know about chinese social
websites but in china
because it's a communist country and the
companies own the whole stack what that
means is almost all the social networks
in china people shop through that [ __ ]
like here instagram shop hasn't caught
on like amazon facebook over here
instagram over here amazon over there
but in china everything's vertically
integrated i think the thing that
everybody will see this year is things
that look like
instagram with nfts what i think i think
instagram is going to have that feature
i think coinbase is going to have that
feature and so
i think that people are going to start
minting almost the way they post on
their social media through those
platforms there's going to be a lot of i
mean i want to remind everybody again
there's some ogs in here they've been
looking at each other they know what i'm
saying a lot of you are youngsters like
[ __ ] man 1990 until marc andreessen
created netscape navigator you had to
actually know how to code to even get on
the internet
which meant on the record i was never on
the internet and i was like i don't know
that [ __ ] one zero one zero [ __ ] that
you know like
so
i mean
again like i used to pay three minutes
three dollars a minute to be on aol
my mom like i used to be on the internet
my mom picked up the phone to call my
aunt and i was off the internet
like i think a lot of us forgot remember
pre-iphone
like if you left the house you weren't
on the internet no more
so like i think we
forget like how it was
and that's what's going on with this
this blockchain [ __ ] right now people
getting their [ __ ] stolen seed phrase a
lot of you are not in because you hear
and it's true people getting their [ __ ]
[ __ ] you think there's [ __ ] [ __ ]
going on the streets people are [ __ ]
getting gangstered every [ __ ] hour
for real money out there on web three
non-custodial custodial there's a ton of
[ __ ] going on so we're just so [ __ ]
early
but in five years all this stuff is
gonna be second nature
all happening on the back end not gonna
know what a [ __ ] seed phrase is it's
all gonna evolve
oh how do you keep your nfc safe then
people say sound like a legend that's
right
and that's and honestly what a cold
wallet a ledger hardware like honestly
this is gonna be beautiful i really feel
like a lot of people who are gonna run
with what tonight's energy was
do what i did what is a hard wallet
enter
read 30 things watch dirty thing you
know what i mean you'll learn
you'll learn
will
cold wallets ever be
digital only like with the people
like will we have a way to digitally
protect
our assets the same way
i think the reason that will always
always be vulnerable is there's a way
for people to take control of your
computer
so i think
what i think is actually gonna happen is
everyone's gonna say [ __ ] it i don't
wanna [ __ ]
control this [ __ ] i'll pay the company
three percent to hold my [ __ ]
and that'd be like the new aws
i mean that's cloud that's
infrastructure but it'll be more like
the new banks
like everyone's gonna be like [ __ ] it
i'm too scared to lose my million dollar
bag i'll let coinbase take three percent
for like con for taking the risk
and that's gonna be a lot of money for
coinbase or chase bank or whoever the
[ __ ] wins it
how do you keep people from minting your
old work
as a new entity
well they don't have the actual like you
mean old images
images are audio for people who do music
like if a engineer have like it's it's
personal it's it's it's really hard i
mean there's people minting my face
my my meme face yesterday people are
selling the [ __ ] out of that right now
on that that's my name image and
likeness
people are just minting away it's still
wild wild west
but but remember
don't get caught up in that here's why
it's going to work itself out because
at the end of the day
like it not being you
matters
like for all the [ __ ] gary vee [ __ ]
that's being put up every hour
like
it's i'm not co-signing it it's not me
and it will have far less economics and
as a matter of fact you know how i look
at it they're just promoting me
let them take those pennies i'll keep
the dollars
my man okay speaking of dollars uh which
what's the future of the dollar in your
opinion
[Music]
um
i don't know but i'll tell you this
governments are not in the business of
giving up control
so this whole nirvana that some people
think of
don't drop bombs on you before they give
up
russia and china have already done it
america will be more clever about it but
but there'd be no confusion
governments are not in the business of
giving up
control
i mean it's crazy when you think about
the dollar
you just print that [ __ ] in perpetuity
blueberries are about to be 74 because
of inflation
you know like you know i'm not sure but
what i'll say is this
if you think a room of these people all
of us here 20 years ago
looking like us
from our backgrounds talked about [ __ ]
like what the dollars being printed like
the world's getting educated
there was nobody talking about the
dollar being off the gold standard in a
room like this 20 [ __ ] years ago
right
so education's coming up it's coming up
and that's going to change the world
but
don't sleep on the ultimate gangster
the government doesn't give a [ __ ]
but there'll be evolution a lot of
[ __ ] are in puerto rico now that
never thought they'd be there
i have a lot of super liberal friends
rushing to get to texas and florida
people will adjust i just flew i just
landed from dubai
there's gonna be a lot of people living
in dubai
because dubai is a business they're
going on the offense they're going to
write laws that are going to make you if
somebody hits and they're not grounded
by children they're going to get their
ass to the desert
so things will evolve
things will evolve
do you think the doubt
yeah i i think i'm very fascinated about
the house i think i would argue that
people
are
trying to rethink dao's because i think
dao is
in the first year of execution
remind me a lot of like communism like
marxism
reads really nice on paper
like i don't know how many people have
read it
yeah like if you read the literature
you're like damn this is how the world
should be
but then the human spirit kicks in
this whole concept of like we're gonna
be decentralized and all decide on
everything there's the best soap operas
in the world right now are in discord
taos where everyone's just mad at each
other and like it's hard to like get
it's hard to have two cooks in the
kitchen
you want to have 113
enjoy it
so i'm in
i short-term invest okay
day trade yeah okay futures okay do you
think that nfts we will speculate on the
value of them the same way we do futures
now in the commodities that we trade in
the futures market do you think that
nfts will make it to the space where
we're
i mean speculating and trading the value
of those i think that's the only thing
that's happening now
everyone's day trading they're all
speculating
the whole i would argue that that's the
entire space
i think that's why the space is going to
collapse so much
all you have is day traders
everyone's like i'm in it for the
community i'm like [ __ ] you
you ain't in for the community you're in
it for the floor you're in for the
community you're in the [ __ ] discord
24 7 saying floor price floor price
floor price
and then [ __ ] [ __ ] you're in for a
quick flip everyone's everyone's in it
in the futures market is backed
by the commodities themselves i
understand will
the mft be backed by the ones like
like in a future market now i don't give
a [ __ ] what the commodity does i make
money whether it goes up or goes down so
in that same fashion with nfts
if the if it's losing that well it's not
ever going to lose value and that's the
thing like i'm wondering with nfts if
you're short-term invested in it like
you said if they sell if you have 10 000
units you sell all your 10 000 units you
never lose value because it already sold
yeah you the issuer made your bag right
but you can still speculate on the value
of it yes it becomes a secondary
derivative right now now it becomes an
asset that the market decides what to do
with when marvel
sold
you know amazing stories 15 and [ __ ]
somebody paid five cents for the first
appearance of spider-man they got their
money
what happened next was interesting
what's cool though for marvel is
when spider-man's first appearance sells
for two million dollars
at an auction they're gonna make two
hundred thousand in the future
michael jordan's rookie card when i buy
that [ __ ] for four hundred thousand
dollars flear doesn't make a dollar
[Music]
yeah which is why all the economics are
going to the creator
which is huge creator
audience puts them on
and then it becomes a [ __ ] it's gonna
be really good now what's gonna happen
is a lot of artists aren't gonna hit
and so like a lot of people like fans
are gonna be mad right
yeah it's like it becomes a new dynamic
that nobody's thought through now when a
[ __ ] artist that somebody [ __ ] with
they found them on the gram they said
i'm a tic-tock they [ __ ] with them on
soundcloud they signed with a label and
the label and the and the record doesn't
hit
they all blame the label
they're like nah i wasn't my guy it was
a [ __ ] label
now it's gonna be different
now when that [ __ ] doesn't hit and isn't
making money the fans are gonna be on
that person's tick tock like yo
why don't you stop [ __ ]
pumping your album i don't give a [ __ ]
that you got the new [ __ ] nikes get
back in the [ __ ] studio
like
like right you know ever
up until this point everything's been
like yeah this is a good ass [ __ ]
this part has repercussions
and let me give you a preview these
[ __ ] on the other side they're
savages i'm
i'm [ __ ] i made people [ __ ]
millions of dollars and my floor goes
from like 13 to like 11 ethan they're
like yo gary what the [ __ ] i'm like what
the [ __ ] you
what do you mean what the [ __ ]
you [ __ ] entitled [ __ ] like
why not board ape like i mean people are
crazy [ __ ] people are [ __ ] crazy
out here
so you better be really ready for your
fans to be [ __ ] different
all of a sudden they're not cheering for
you they feel like they're on the
[ __ ] board
they're like what are you doing
so like you know pros and cons with
now instead of having one person you got
to report to the label you're going to
have 5 000. so it's good listen there's
pros and cons you think this crater
economy is blowing because the old
american economic model is slowly dying
no i just think it's options
right like like
in my corporate life they're like yo
yeah because i'm by far the most
contemporary person in my game they're
like yo these [ __ ] kids they don't
want to work i'm like they want to work
they want to work for themselves
the [ __ ] do you think they want to work
for you make it 45k while you treat them
like [ __ ] they want they'll make 45k on
[ __ ] adsense
this is you know everyone's talking
about the great resignation
and that's like a big talk in my
corporate world like all these people
that are just quitting i'm like wait
till you see i'm like don't worry about
the great resignation wait till you see
the great never applied in the [ __ ]
first place
that shit's gonna really [ __ ] them up
between nfts between tick-tock between
[ __ ] kids are getting educated
the [ __ ] are you going to get a
it's crazy
to [ __ ] take a minimum wage job in
america
the biggest reason i do trash talk my
garage sale videos some of you have seen
is i'm just trying to tell people like
yo for real like
like you can buy anything at a garage
like
isn't it better than going to work at
wendy's for like just buy seven things
at a garage sale on saturday make the
same amount of money like and people
like whoa
gas i'm like you spend gas to go to
wendy's too like you know like what
about shipping charge them for shipping
like
yeah i mean
yeah i think i just think it's options
the economy could be amazing it could be
the greatest thing of all time
this is just that the internet is here
and now the blockchain
just
options you know so
the friends did well yeah that means you
this might be suitable no go ahead
you got it in heath yep that means
you're paying ridiculous gas fees as
well as refresh dates
yeah it costs to mint it yeah yeah to
even cement it just to get it out after
well once you get all the eat
no not the the
there's no gas fees like to like convert
to e now
i'm saying to convert out of into
usd
a little bit a couple dollars
a couple dollars no no no no it's
nothing
it's not even going to register in your
mind so when you alright so say if our
artist does get there thanks for coming
so their nfts thanks for coming of
course they won't have to move it to
another crypto to get it out
no like like to aj's point like there's
a couple of dollars there and
transferring out but like it's really
really minimum
the question the biggest question for
you is you sell something
you definitely want to take 50 cents on
the dollar off to pay your tax bill
because i i sold v friends and ethereum
was 4 800 and within three weeks it was
1700
and that was not a fun time for me
anyway i gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
thank you
[Applause]
you